[Music]
you're gonna get us wrong the show has
been such a launchpad for so many people
working on the show I know some of the
guys here doing the Deadpool animated
series but you're not dominant can you
tell me about you know Domino and
Deadpool's dynamic yeah well I think
Domino kind of meets that bull
head-to-head and doesn't really take
just fit him she's strong and she's
sarcastic and sardonic and I think
darkly funny in the way that Deadpool is
okay any Zazi beats career is hotter
than ever not only is she making her
mark in the superhero vers
she's also returning to the hit FX drama
d Atlanta Robin season season she was
finally here I'm so excited what can you
tell me about you know the biggest
differences between season wanted to
season two is a lot a heavier darker I
think you can but it just kind of
doubles down on the I think the drama in
the show but also within so many surreal
moments I need to know if the invisible
cars coming back like so coy about the
invisible car one thing I read was that
this season is inspired by Tiny Toons
how I spent my summer vacation which is
one of my favorite is true and how is
that tiny - you have to watch
it's not time to hang with your best
friend I think there's just a little bit
of playfulness within it all and I felt
very much particularly sinner maybe it's
just because I'm just a lot more
comfortable than I was the first time
around but we were just kind of just
playing and we were just doing
everything like playing and playing and
I think happens at the end of on screen
is unscripted and it just you know what
we played with
[Music]